sono passati anni dall'uscita di inside
e finalmente oggi esce il gioco di quel
genere ma bellissimo che non vedevo
l'ora di giocare stiamo su sea of
solitude che è questo non lo so che
cos'è però è molto stile inside che era
avventura abbia inizio ragazzi sono
completamente distrutta ai famiglie ad
amici eppure si è andata da sola
all'idroscalo cioè questo che parla il
protagonista di tutto questo va disposto
casinò e la protagonista
un giorno però la mia grandissima
domanda è ma scusami ma come ci si è
finita qua c'è visto che questo è un
gioco fatto proprio della serie fatto
bene e voglio dire è coesa socio questo
vorrei capirlo
va bene ma va io comando la barchetta
ragazzi questo resti of solito queste sì
of this andiamo a prendere i tesori va
bene quindi io sono questa ragazza che
ma non è una luce tipo e trilli e
thriller di peter pan
ciao trilli arrivo 6 ferma mai
[Musica]
cosa è successo oddio mi installato la
nuova scheda grafica nvidia ma vedevo il
sole non so quanto c'è il mi ha
scacciato delusione
porca vacca maison si crea quindi prima
ma che fiat ai ragazzi ma che gioco
incredibile va bene comunque ragazzi o
venezia me la ricordavo un po diversa
però back to black
ma come non ci credo ha detto è stata
vista in casinò o ragazzi non lo sapevo
io l'ho detto a caso non avevo giocato
prima aveva detto la stessa cosa e stati
qui tantissimo va bene allora si è
beccato una casa in pieno in piena
faccia un attimo c'è già io non ho la
patente figurati se devo mettermi a fare
il gondoliere è un casino qua mi pagano
neanche per sa cosa cioè non sono un
portone anche la gente c'è dobbiamo
giocare a nascondino a venezia va bene
lo mettevi a giocare a nascondino
costati ma perché stati famosa in tutto
questo perché è tutto allagato così sto
che è lui che è successo ma perché
diventa tutto nero maledizione music
cristo buongiorno
ma tua sorella
ma cosa devo fare quando spaccarlo con
la luce spaccati
beh ho mancato il bersaglio di tanto ma
perché lo spara sulla forza perché devo
andare lì ho capito c'è un casino weiler
i've got a bus sciandrone tutti in barca
ok
sembra una ragazza uccello perché ciò le
piume pro caino a un aiuto non funziona
ciò dei vermi che mi attaccano elimina
corruzione vabbè corrompi ti da solo
mentre in staino strano che figlio ma
water cosa è successo
[Musica]
no ragazzo gioca veramente strano
quindi ragazzi ho colpito in coso con sì
però stai calmo zio senso easy devo
trovare altra luce ai quindi devo
colpire questo acqua di puntino il
discorso ragazzi che un gioco veramente
incasinato però è fatto benissimo
oh mio dio granze rivivere noto sordi
per questo è veramente orribile st
madonna che ansia concentrati sul mostro
ma che concentrati
mi sono fatto addosso
va bene cosa ma due
teoricamente adesso dovrei riuscire a
farlo fuori
l'ho fatto ho acceso due fanali e fatta
la madonna è brutta ordine certo che
veramente la mattina potresti anche
pettinati lui l'ho amato che figata
esatto poi c'è la mia barchetta di tutto
questo c'è l'acqua grigia qui non vorrei
buttarmi giù però devo farlo credo
aspetta non è che il mostro non sia in
agguato però va beh proviamoci sono
fatta
sì ci ho fatto che fate ma perché il
grigio miss mi mette sempre ansia prova
bene capitolo due emozioni mixate come
martin garics
adesso capisco il mose mio dio che
figata
sto gioco incredibile non devo
ovviamente usare la barca perché la
barca non va il nostro bar preferito
questo gap h
ma basta arrivo
io mi sono affidato comunque mi sono
buttato davvero però non non sei
simpatica fattelo dire quindi devo
dribblarla fino ad arrivare al coso lì
davanti concentrati sul mostro
eccolo manopole la luce di prima va bene
io seguo cerco di arrivare fin lì allora
nella porta teoricamente lui non ci
passa quindi posso anche entrarci
chissenefrega
non è che visto dove è importante
esserci salvati mamma mia ragazzi che
gioco assurdo mi fido nora che mi sono
fidato troppo invece sono fatta pazzesco
per una volta la mia vita che mi fido di
me stesso e funziona
penso sia l'unica volta ora gesù ti
prego ti prego no basta madonna ragazzi
questo tica in testa un problema come
che tristezza
vedi un affare the sound of silence
alexa metti the sound of silence alexa
basta fece mente non scopre le ragazze
questo un problema però del sound of
silence me la trigger ha tantissimo
e la madonna manco toccare l'acqua qua
anch'io
alla fine siamo entrati dentro come il
mio ragazzo sta riguardando sunny
sarebbe mia sorella no aiuto aiuto
ma cosa madonna nera che che ansia però
non è che possono inseguirmi i bambini o
prova a fare il giro contrario magari
funziona tipo da qua esatto ok per una
volta ho una mia idea ha funzionato e
sono già due in un video o incredibile
ma perché sono proprio pezzenti sti qua
o comunque ti possono toccare al massimo
una volta quanto ho capito o mio dio
spara segnale luminoso vai potevo fare
così anche prima di mirò ti prego
a questi non libertà fuori occhio senti
giovanni cristo aspetta ma si sono fatti
fuori da soli
molto bene molto bene molto bene a mo di
sopra l'ha fatta gente che c'è il suo
posto praticamente la scuola è finita ai
ragazzi di piccoli era qualche bruti
rappresentano la l'infanzia di sunny che
il mio fratellino che vorrebbe essere il
corno reincarnato credo quindi i
ragazzini lo prendevano in giro a scuola
questo dovrebbe essere teoricamente
quello che ho capito se ho capito c'è
alla fine per recuperare la mia barca i
dari quanti chilometri io mi debba fare
c'è un casino veramente mandato il tizio
eccolo pure il pitone in faccia di si
credono comunque veramente per
recuperarla barca ci mettono anni cioè
stalla diritto riccamente non dovrebbe
riuscire a prendermi perché è luminoso
giusto
altro che the sound of silence è sì beh
anch'io vorrei la mia barchetta
ma che bello ha guardato vista mio dio è
lontanissimo dovrà aggiungere sunny con
la mia fratello teoricamente quindi
dovrei aver capito questo quindi tutti
in realtà sono degli ti mostri sono dei
delle persone nella mia vita piacere
sunny non dirmi che la boxe fight mi
ammazzo
come facevamo fatto niente sto zitto
dall'inizio del gioco a frate sehgal ma
dai è tranquillo ma sono qua per te no
maledizione
è successo questa città che bomba quindi
ragazzi questa dal primo episodio di sea
of solitude da diversi of silence da
quando ho sentito del sound of silence
però vi sia piaciuto è un gioco molto
particolare però è fatto bene quindi mi
piace un sacco spero vi piaccia è molto
introspettivo lasciate mi piace
iscriviti al canale ghiacciato alla
campanella prima nelle sempre giornata
dice video che escono e noi ragazzi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video beh
ragazzi
[Musica]